tall buildings
big highways comfortable homes
a car for every family
for years these have been the symbols of
modern life
but only a small part of the world's
population can afford such a life
the same is true of health care
there are very few hospitals in
developing countries where treatment is
given free
these hospitals can't cope with the
health needs of all the poor people in
the cities
so much money has been poured into big
hospitals and sophisticated equipment
by governments all around the world that
it affects the training of medical
students
they learn their job on expensive
equipment
they are trained more in curative than
preventive medicine
many of them aim to become specialists
few
are taught to concern themselves with
basic health care
this kidney machine costs more than ten
thousand dollars
one nurse has to be in attendance at all
hours
this raises questions about the
allocation of resources
so much technology so many highly
skilled people engaged in saving a few
lives
so little money so few qualified people
involved in tackling basic health needs
around the world
how can doctors and nurses use their
skills for these wider needs
small groups of doctors in several
countries have begun seeking ways to do
so
bangladesh faces these problems as
sharply as any country in the world
health care is inadequate in its few big
cities
it is even less adequate in rural areas
in noah kali district where 120 000
people live
there are three doctors at the health
center they do an important job in
treating drastic cases
but they realize that a single district
hospital will always be overcrowded
they also realized that since healthcare
should consist
more of preventive than curative work it
need not depend
primarily on doctors and nurses so
they set out to train paramedical
workers and to create a network
of five sub-centers where there are
clinics
[Applause]
there's a clinic within two miles of
every home these are run by an assistant
nurse
with clinic assistants who have only
five weeks training before tackling work
like malaria cases
they also run special clinics for
children under five
keeping a record of each child's health
and giving immunization
at these clinics they also supply a
daily food supplement
wheat mixed with chickpea to 4 000 young
children
the assistants often visit women in
their homes giving advice on nutrition
immunizations and family planning
a doctor isn't needed for any of these
jobs but he visits each sub-center twice
a week for serious cases
[Music]
health cannot be studied as something
separate in a community
it is linked to every aspect of
development to sanitation and clean
water supplies
and to food production
especially in countries where there is
heavy population pressure on the land
health care depends very directly upon
the people being able to make the most
productive use of all the land available
only in that way will large families be
able to enjoy enough nutritious food
so how broad should the functions of a
health worker be
there is no single answer it is
different between countries
and within a single country
panama is a country with 9 000 small
communities
scattered in the mountains and along
jungle rivers
each group of communities has to work
out its own needs
and how to tackle them
near cologne a village began with a
household survey
collecting facts on people of all ages
[Music]
they paid particular concern to the
growth and the state of health of the
younger children
members of the community health
committee across section of the
villagers
analyzed the statistics from the survey
then they held a meeting for the whole
community putting the facts before them
they heard people's concerns and
together they planned a community
program of action
one measure they decided on with
hospital officials and the medical
officer who's in charge of public health
in the province
was to choose and train a medical
assistant
the people elected their own medical
assistant marciana harado
someone they knew could do the job they
had just defined
she is trained at the district health
center and goes back there once a week
for further training
and to get medical supplies
she is also trained how to move around
the community encouraging people in many
efforts of self-improvement
she is mostly on her own and coping with
a wide range of jobs
that go beyond the normal boundaries of
mother and child health care
for example she advises on improvements
to sanitation
in three years 40 other assistants like
marciana
have been selected and given basic
training in cologne
and they are now working as part of the
provincial health team
in their villages they are the health
team and something more important
they have shown the community what it
can do once it starts to mobilize its
own resources
in a very different culture in northeast
thailand
the medical faculty of khan ken
university asked officials in 16
provinces
what was most wanted in health care back
came the answer from the villages
someone nearby to consult when we are
ill
so dr kawi and his staff began simple
training courses in 1975
for village health volunteers unlike
bangladesh and panama
these are part-time health workers who
earn their living by farming
training courses are short two or three
weeks at a time
but they attend several courses over a
period of two years
the university has found there is a need
for more appropriate teaching materials
for this new level of pupils
it makes do with some traditional
equipment but it does its utmost to give
realistic training
[Applause]
the series of short courses should equip
a village health worker with the skills
to treat
common illnesses mr michai a farmer who
lives 50 miles from khan kim
treats malaria and diarrhea gives advice
on nutrition and family planning
and tells villagers how to protect
themselves against parasites
he also knows when and how to refer
difficult cases
the villagers appreciate mr michai's
work
they built a small clinic for him
[Music]
in canada also some rural communities
have shown
they know best what they need in health
care
a group of indian leaders told health
officials the best way was a broad
educational approach
health they said wasn't just a segment
of somebody's life
it covered everything from how and where
they placed a house and found clean
water supplies
to their daily food needs
[Applause]
in 1964 the government of canada began
training community health
representatives at fort capel
saskatchewan
eugenie lavallee was one of the first
working in her own payapot indian
reserve
as she explains her job led her into
teaching many things
the minute i graduated from the fort
that was the first thing i did i had to
come and
talk to the chief and then the nurse and
i had a very good nurse i can't say that
much because she was always out there
if i had a meeting she was there and
that used to be a big
lift because at that time even i
belonged here i was still afraid you
know
i needed somebody there to give me
courage
i used to go by seasons accidents in the
winter
and you know in the spring it was x-rays
for tb and stuff like that and they
cleaned up
and then in july it used to be more or
less gardening and
so is in august it was judging of the
gardens and
but everything pertaining to health is
what you know
what i worked on on the long run i think
i
made it and i quit last year
not rich at all brooke but a lot of lot
of friends
she has retired now but is still very
much involved in community affairs
as an indian band counselor and member
of the school board
she has handed on her job on the health
team to violet payapot
violet works closely with the nurse who
visit your clinic
the nurse gives immunizations
violet keeps the health records of each
child
she also spends time with the children
in school teaching them about a good
balanced diet
[Applause]
[Music]
you drink a lot of milk yeah
home visits talking to people at leisure
and in their own cree language
are a very important part of the
community health representative's work
well i was always interested in people i
think that was my main
maybe main reason and towards the end
this is
one of my biggest thrills was visiting
around
we used to talk about anything i never
never put pressure or any on anybody
unless it was urgent you know like i
used to just more or less give them
hello and talk about
maybe the stars or something you know
just anything
just kind of break that ice go easy
and then advertising the clinic date you
know mark their calendar
and things like that and uh so they
won't forget
so you know it's it's the trust and the
confidence
of the people that i think i always
worked on first
[Music]
in saskatchewan they were told not to
take people to hospitals
except in an emergency in venezuela
they don't need to be told that the
distances for most people to any big
hospital are too great
in the upper reaches of the oronoco
river the rocks and rapids are a barrier
to movement
but the river is still the main highway
in southern venezuela
[Music]
omania parato a medical auxiliary visits
his group of villages by dugout canoe
powered these days by a 30 horsepower
outboard motor
[Music]
he has had six months training and he
needs all that training to be
self-reliant
because although the system of
simplified medicine calls for regular
supervision
in practice the size of the area is too
large for a community nurse to cover
thoroughly
he takes and checks malaria swabs in his
[Music]
clinic
he makes house to house visits around
the villages
many children suffer from malnutrition
in the amazonia's jungle area
he tries to treat such cases before the
weakened child is infected with other
diseases
[Music]
back in his home village he calls the
people for a general talk on hygiene
[Music]
it is 60 miles by river past many rapids
to the regional hospital at puerto
acucho
only the worst cases of emergency are
taken there
the child needing a blood transfusion
the baby who has been born months
premature
iran is a final example of these trends
in health care
it has 12 000 doctors but half of them
practice in the capital tehran
and most of the rest work in other big
towns
[Music]
yet 20 million people still live in
rugged countryside
and there are some 20 000 villages of
less than 100 population
[Music]
how can a country provide an effective
system of health care
for these small scattered communities dr
hussein ronaghi of pallava university
had a plan in 1972 for a new level of
health worker
we thought that we can do
some of the primary health work
by the villagers themselves train them
in the village and deploy them
in the village working as a health
worker
this was an experimental program
something similar to barefoot doctors of
china
but in different socioeconomic
and political situation such as iran
[Music]
what are the health needs of iran what
are the basic health needs of iran and
do we need
really a major center with all multi
specialty clinic and multi-speciality
or can we expand our money and have our
priority in the villages
which has the basic health problem upper
respiratory tract infection
in the winter and diarrhea in the summer
these are two major killer in
two seasons by only treating these
two major problems and
improving the nutritional status of the
children
we have certainly contributed a lot to
the health of
our population
[Music]
mrs borghar is one of 46 literate
villagers in
forest province who trained for six
months in a health center
[Music]
back in her village she makes home
visits to give advice on hygiene and
sanitation
[Music]
she also inspects water supplies
[Music]
[Applause]
she believes in teaching good health
habits to all ages but especially to the
young
so she often gives talks in the school
with 33 million population of iran we
have only
a pool of 12 000 physician even if we
would have enough physicians even if we
would have
a 60 000 position they would not
probably be suitable for that kind of
situation of
a community of 100 so there would be no
choice but to create a kind of manpower
socially economically and mentally
suitable for that kind of community
[Music]
the village health worker is the first
level in the health care system
second comes the badar who has had four
years training
then the physician at the healthcore
station and finally the hospital
dr roniki explains what
we have done is to create
a system which is start from the village
which has vhw village head worker
taking care of preventive measures and
doing some
therapeutic work in major
and most important disease then they
would refer
the complicated cases to effort level
which is called badar
bedar would do at least
90 percent of the problem and refer
the 10 of the problem to the health
center
which is equipped by a physician this is
a health core system
which has 400 different posts all over
iran
and these are by young physician who
are doing their military work for two
years
in the villages whenever there is a
complicated
case which i would believe is less than
one percent of the cases
we can refer them to university hospital
and this is the idea of having the
village health worker
beddar healthcore physician and
university hospital
as a comprehensive healthcare for the
entire nation
there are still only a few village
health workers in iran
but these few have proved their worth
village health workers are only part of
a total health system
in iran or elsewhere but they can be the
foundation block upon which the whole
pyramid is built if it is to be a solid
structure
there must be a good way for one level
to supervise the work of the level below
and it must be easy for workers at any
level to put forward ideas about changes
that can help improve the whole
structure the village health workers
being closest to the people have a voice
that should be heard
these are only six examples of trends in
rural health care
other countries will find their own ways
drawing on their own traditions
but seeking the same goal a better life
for all their people
[Music]
[Music]
you